Ken Ham who we mentioned earlier was in
the debate with Bill Nye the Science Guy
a couple weeks ago debating science
versus creation he is now building an
ark yeah just like Noah he is building
an ark Noah's Ark very hot these days by
the way so yeah he's building a 73
million dollar replica of Noah's Ark he
has raised enough money already to do
this it's it's part of a proposed Bible
themed park that he's putting together
in Kentucky of course and groundbreaking
is planned for May and it should be
finished by 2016 so they got a nice logo
there and everything see the water the
way it goes into the Ark that's pretty
pretty good so it's gonna look something
like this and then we also have an image
of the park itself so this is what the
park they want it to look like really is
just being a lot of people that's very
optimistic if it's anything like
Universal yeah kind of crazy so
expensive that's good all right so yeah
so Noah's Ark is very hot right now
there's actually a Noah movie coming out
we thought we'd show you a little bit of
that in case you're not familiar with
Noah himself
it begins
when they come there will be desperate
and there will be many
is it Noah's Ark or is it gladiator -
who knows ok alright so there's a lot we
can go with this so first off one of the
things I mean I remember learning about
this when I was a kid about Noah's Ark
and the one thing that always struck me
as the most ridiculous part of it was
the - the two animals of everything
because how would that even how's he
gonna get every insect how's he get you
know it's just like but I know you can't
talk about it in a rational and so also
oh there are three monkeys two monkeys
and their baby [ __ ] you baby monkey no
we don't want you baby monkey just do
just your parents sorry right right
exactly so there's okay so all the
rational arguments for why it's nuts and
it should be viewed as a metaphor and
it's an allegory okay but how do we
reconcile again this goes to a lot of
things we've been talking about but how
do we reconcile the people that want to
literally believe this versus the people
that want to be how do we exist in the
same space engine cattle admin she's my
neighborhood scary oh hey you know what
are you gonna do I mean there are people
who just believe this and there's no
talking to them yeah I mean how do you
explain that how do you explain all the
species being gathered I really would
like to hear kenneth ham or he's also
gonna use scientific principles to build
the park which is the part that no one
ever talks about your the things that
you're gonna need the levers and pulleys
you're gonna need stuff that is based in
science to do the very thing while at
the same time you're gonna denigrate
science yeah it's it's so crazy no
whatever nobody ever talks about like
what about all the other people who had
boats back then it's you this no movie
it's so funny did you see that there
there's a disclaimer on it because
they're worried that it does not
represent a biblical truth and so
there's a slamming for the movie saying
that there have been changes made to the
true story that we still feel are in
essence with the that's like it's all a
fake story
moving that's a crazy thing Darren
Aronofsky who from the Black Swan in
requiem bridge yeah
also Darren Aronofsky's Noah sounds so
much like a line of dialogue from
Entourage it's not even funny like this
cannot be a real movie yeah so we've had
this big burst suddenly in religious
films and TV shows you know we had the
Bible on the History Channel it was like
the biggest rated show of the year we
had son of god movie which i think is
out now or it's about to cut down of the
Bible it was cut into it's the same
people it's actually they took like
three episodes of the show and turned it
into him is that right and they did take
the devil out apparently because
remember everyone was going crazy
because the devil looked like Obama in
the TV show so they didn't want that in
the movie because it would overshadow
the bigger themes but what is going on
here in America because on one end I do
think that the science stuff and
rationality is winning and then on the
other hand you know now it sounds like
Mike Huckabee is probably gonna run in
2016
you always got Santorum back there like
we don't seem to be able to fully move
on what where is this coming from the
fact that the show you know the shows
are doing well the movies obviously know
is going to be a blockbuster audience is
a very big audience I mean there's a the
religious right is very strong and then
you have you know the the Tea Party is
is you know really hanging in there and
there's a very big audience that buys it
it's all I mean look at these mega
churches all over the place in the cross
country trip to come here there are a
lot of mega churches I think it's a I
think it's a natural pendulum swing I
think as science gets stronger the
religious opposition to science gets
stronger because they feel like they are
in opposition to science and so if
science is having advancements then they
have to be stronger they have to be
bigger than to be louder
I do think Sciences is winning I think
things like that Bill Nye talked the
Bill Nye debate with him was so absurd
the his counter arguments about just
total you know but they change
did it change any hearts and minds cuz I
remember watching and he comes back with
rational explanations but if you don't
believe it
then it's I don't I can't imagine the
person that's a believer that suddenly
is like you're that's
we true for the most part but I would
say there's very little chance that Ken
Ham changed any hearts and minds and if
one of them changed hearts and minds it
had to be Bill Nye look I I don't think
that anybody walked out of that walked
into it believing science walked out of
it believe in Ken Ham yeah but I do
think there's a solid chance that one or
two or three people locked into a
balloon Ken Ham heard what bill and I
had to say and maybe yeah walk out
change but walked out questioning but
you know but the audience also that they
were doing it in front of was was a camp
basically a Ken Ham audience these
people were not open I mean I really
don't think that these mines were open
right but it was broadcast I think it
was on MSNBC yeah but I was I was raised
very strictly Catholic in the mid in the
Midwest and going to all boy Catholic
High School and and you know being
taught as late as high school you know
we were taught about you know like the
DSM from 1970 that said homosexuality
was a mental disorder like was still
being taught to us in the early 2000s as
though that were real like that's where
I came from and somehow I ended up you
know how did you break it well I mean
when I was in junior high I was a
big-time you know as much as you could
be anything I was a conservative my
parents are conservative I you know I
was excited when George Bush beat al
gore and I thought Al Gore was a sore
loser and whatever within two years I
you know just started questioning I mean
the moment for me specifically was
Stephanie Tubbs Jones the late Stephanie
Tubbs Jones former congressman I hate it
from Cleveland who died a few years ago
in a car accident she came to speak at
our all-boys Catholic school so we had
this black liberal democratic woman to
come speak to a roomful of 6900 we would
have a speaker series
who brought somebody like that yeah it
was a judgment school so there were some
there were some liberal minded people
there but she was asked about her view
on abortion at that speech and the
school booed her a bunch of 1600 white
men
bood a black lesbian or not lesbian
sorry black liberal Democrat pictures
lesbian black liberal Democrat woman
Democrat woman on abortion and I
remember at the time being so disgusted
and just being like huh
don't know about this and then slowly
teachers and stuff you know start to
have an effect than teachers have an
effect that's I think our education
speech interieur education no I I think
you're totally right I think that's what
happened to me I found teachers that you
know opened my mind and made me question
things and eventually you know to New
York that's the key if your mind is
closed it's closed and if there's no way
in there's no way in so in the spirit of
open minds my final question on this
will be I know it's easy for us to sort
of be glib about these people and the
belief system and all that but should we
just let them have their Park should we
let them have their God and eat it too
you know you mean like is it really that
bad if they just have their Park that
they can go to or just because of the
political system and everything else
that it actually is because they can
vote against people's rights yeah I
think the problem is yeah I mean I think
they should have the right to worship
whatever they want and they should
believe whatever they want I think but
as the old saying goes like your rights
and at your fist in my nose like that
rhymes and immunity but like I think
when though when their religious rights
begin infringing on other people's human
rights that becomes a problem and there
it does need to be some sort of and it
does increasingly yeah yeah
and I think the the true future of it
should be a world and this is an
idealist utopian idea but a world where
that they can real where people can
realize that religion and science can
co-exist and can live to get you like I
I know Bill Nye has said that he doesn't
believe in God and like he doesn't see
them as as you know interacting that way
but I think if you are already believing
in a God who invented the world whole
cloth why can't you believe that he
invented these complicated systems like
that doesn't that doesn't make sense
that's pretty much because it doesn't
fit into your paradigm that's it just
doesn't work that's
it the important thing is that these
religious organizations won't have to
pay taxes I think we could thank you
that is a big deal right there